marcus makes a movie this is a book that
i decided to write to inspire the youth
the generation today i feel like the
word no is powerful
is discouraging and sometimes you do
need a a little uh
a little push and understanding that no
it's not forever
it's it's a moment and this is the book
of a guy
a young kid that heard the word no and
didn't want to accept it
and he wanted to create his opportunity
which is what life is about it's about
creating and making opportunities making
the best of them and having the ambition
to drive to do it
stay with it ultimately succeed for
whatever that level of success is
in this case it was about making his
dream movie
uh that he was told he couldn't do
because he had no money he had no
cameras
and he found a way to do it without
having those assets
but by just having the help of some
friends uh
ambition and ultimately a dream and a
dream comes true but it's a nice journey
it's a good journey and i want kids to
understand that's what life is
life is a journey a journey worth living
and embracing you know why
because at the end of it we all get to
look back at our story and marcus's
story
it's amazing wow did i sum that up hit
me away
yes that was awesome
i feel inspired first of all right now
i'm crushing it
what was your experience like um i don't
know did you ever have you ever told no
about something and then you feel like
you've pushed through any way that you
could do it somebody told you you can't
do something and you did well kelly
first and foremost let me take the time
to echo what you just said
okay because kelly that was a great it
was a great question all right i feel i
was totally i was so nervous
okay we all were told no's at some point
in time kelly but here's the thing
my nose ultimately became my driving
want toward
my yes right i was told that i wasn't
funny i was told that i wasn't going to
make it i was just trying to
told you that several i was told that my
movies would never show
overseas and do business overseas i was
told the likelihood of me being a movie
star
was not likely i was told everything
that is the complete opposite of what i
now
am and here's the thing when i was told
that
i didn't get angry i didn't get mad i
just used it as personal fire for myself
because i believed in a certain thing
that i felt i had you are marcus i am
marcus
marcus comes from me it comes from my
life uh
and in my story we just did it in a way
to where kids would be able to identify
with it as well
yeah the word no once again is temporary
it's not forever man
and that's the biggest thing that i want
this young generation to truly
understand i love that dream big
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever